him
I'll show you in the Bible
to really understand what I'm saying
people
this evil man here
foreign
[Music]
something
you know the Jewish people
or someone who is a righteous person
okay
Allah foreign
that's human nature it's not God's
nature God God doesn't have no son not
to do go create us like he creates other
creation to follow his teachings
to worship him along to be grateful to
you him to remember him that's why you
Mr Moses
all of them
because themselves as a righteous person
[Applause]
talking trees
[Laughter]
because you try to resemble Allah
[Music]
all right
have a god
I'm going to my book and you're good to
my father for Jesus and you know who is
that girl is the father so it doesn't
make sense
doesn't make any sense
it's a matter
okay thank you very much
all right it was nice talking to you
take care of yourself have a nice
holiday